hi and welcome back to poker takes this
episode I feel mighty she'll be my
favorite so far not because I have taken
way over an hour and made it way too
complicated to get this woody to be all
finished and good but because I feel
like the coaster creator sort of proved
itself over here to be very honest I was
in the beginning still quite skeptical
of the park attack coaster creators
especially since it's so very similar to
rollercoaster tycoon and I just don't
have to form of memories of that but I
do think that the artists it's improved
over roller coaster tycoon all the games
of roller coaster tycoon and I think
there are two big factors in that it's
like the fact that everybody who's seen
bowler coated wooden roller coasters in
Monaco second three probably knows about
this it's they've got airtime Hills but
they're very unsmooth you don't have the
right transitions between the steep
sections that go up in one way or down
in one way or even steep sections and
straight sections it all goes really
quickly and it just makes rise very
unsmooth but it also makes airtime just
way too big and probably the average
woody in roller coaster q3 is probably
pretty lethal and another thing is that
I've always felt like transitioning to
curves and we're in roller coasters in
Walla Kousaka 3 was just impossible to
get it right it was also it was always a
bit jagged and just not really working
out too well and those are like the two
main things which I feel like this game
so far the coaster creator is actually
perfect for four wooden roller coasters
that you have those amazing transitions
from banks to non-banks curves or from
gentle to straight curves which i think
is pretty amazing and so far I do like
this this wooden roller coaster as well
in general really it's it's got a layout
which you can't even get in water
coaster tycoon 3 to be very honest but
it's arguably also much much more smooth
than any wooden roller coaster you can
ever make in Monaco circuit 3 I mean I
can probably still yeah those a lot
actually that I still need to improve on
when it comes to this Costa crater but
at least
with little to no experience in it I've
managed to build this witty which I
think in the end I'm pretty proud of and
can't say that I think I can I kind of
like it in the end and yeah I'm really
happy about that so I don't know when
I'll be able to do with more practice
but so far I'm really happy about the
editor and this coaster in general when
it comes to names though I feel like I
can have as much experience as I want in
anything I'm never going to be able to
be good at coming up with names so so
far this coaster is called the bullying
thunder and yeah that's pretty much it
if anybody has a good name I guess you
can always shout that because I'm just
really bad at it I might just take it I
have no idea
then again names are not too important
but um yeah I'm just happy about it
I'm happy about the Rolling Thunder it's
it's pretty good so far
except that ending point that actually
took very long to get right one of one
of like my there are a few things which
I am a bit salty about in the editor
like the fact if you've got two tracks
next to each other and one of them is
banked it doesn't work like it you can
only have two tracks next to each other
if they are straight or banked outwards
from each other but if they're both
banked into the same direction it just
doesn't work it turns red which is a bit
painful since it means you can't really
have curves that are very close to each
other so you can't get those beautiful
like double helixes and you can't also
have like one curve coming up to a
straight section and you know going from
bank to straight because nope you can't
have anything banked when it tries to
join another straight track piece which
is a bit annoying but other than that
those are not really too big constraints
really it sort of worked out in the end
so yeah I'm quite happy about it really
one thing which I'm probably not so
happy about it was the randomly quickly
it broke this is like a very stupid
station actually and I just felt like
putting down one big like log hotel it's
it's it's actually inspired and this is
gonna sound like the most stupid thing
ever but it's inspired by the like
Alpine Lodge who tells something in a
game called ski resort I kun does
anybody know that game probably if
you do know that game then yeah that's
cool that's I suppose there's nothing
more to say about that it's it's cool to
know that game I guess but um it's like
a really old game which I used to play a
lot as well alongside rollercoaster
tycoon but yeah I just kind of felt like
I'm building a Alpine park over here so
I might want to draw some inspiration
from that but in the end it didn't
really work out as well as planned so
sort of quickly you wanted to move over
to other things from that sort of
awkward station I think it's not too bad
but it's really not the entire thing
that I was envisioning in my mind to be
quite honest the only other things that
I've really tried for this ride though
is to just get a simple lake and some
mountains around it wooden coaster you
shouldn't really have well normally
doesn't really have too much scenery
going on so this is just gonna be one
big standard wooden rollercoaster
actually yeah it's it's sort of inspired
by the werewolf in wallaby belgium which
I think officially has a French name
which I'm not even trying to pronounce
over here and sort of in the same style
of the bakoma wood is that do exist it
just does curves and that's pretty much
it now you've seen me or anything else
hopefully it's a bit more smooth than
the average become a wooden roller
coaster but that's up for the game to
decide I guess it runs pretty well so
I'm happy about that
it's it's got some good pacing as well
extra credit over here by the way it
goes out to most ex machina
he's just caught my time on the forums I
believe who actually made these diagonal
wooden supports and by the time that I
am commentating this he's also made a
dinosaur custom serie pack which
actually has some really amazing foliage
in it as well but sadly this was
recorded quite a while ago so I can't
quite use that but that's something to
see in the future I guess and yeah
especially with these diagonal supports
and actually works quite well with the
supports in game that's one thing which
I've always hated rollercoaster tycoon 3
for which so far in this game actually
got rights is the fact that it has to
deal with and supports it is
so damn awkward to have a 3d game but
have those to deepen in supports like
even if it causes more lag
I'd much rather just see these 3d
supports for winning roller coaster
types really the only thing that I have
an issue with when it comes to
supporting in this game I don't know if
you noticed but if you go below 4 meters
in Heights so that would be like one
time or above the ground it just stops
supporting so you got floating tracks if
you're somewhat close to the ground
which is very painful but I'm quite sure
that's something to fix to be fixed
later on so I'm not really too worried
about that at the moment but yeah that's
why there are actually some floating
parts of this roller coaster here and
there and which is a bit painful but I
really can't do too much about it other
than weights and the developers at the
moment are still just working on core
features rather than small bugs inside
things so it's probably something that
we'll see in the distant future and this
was a bit of I think still terraforming
no this actually worked out a lot better
I think Oh nope I didn't I think I still
yeah this this was the exact moment
where I was still trying to use the hill
tool to make a lake and that was the
most annoying thing ever and I should
have used the flattening tool which is
so much easier for terraforming and it's
really an eye opener though I do have to
say that Hill - was still bit painful
being able to use the flatten tool is
make things a lot easier and there's
some simple foliage I guess templates I
just like randomly commentating over
what's happening isn't that the premise
of this series anyway it's pretty much
pretty much it there's not not even too
much interesting stuff happening over
here to be very honest I'm just kind of
placing foliage that's simple stuff
though yeah that's actually one of my
other complaints I know when to turn
this into became into a complain series
which is something that I'll get to in a
minute but it's the fact that you can be
placed objects by placing other objects
is
for pretty much anything I would sign of
a forest since if you want to get a
dense forest if you go into
rollercoaster q3 you just hover all over
the park and spam mouse clicks like it's
no big deal but in this game you would
actually replace every single tree you
already built by placing more trees
which is kind of counterproductive so
it's quite hard to actually make a dense
forest you're really gonna have to find
the open spots that you want to make
more dense and fit your trees in exactly
and as soon as as soon as you miss one
by one inch you remove another tree by
placing one which is just annoying and
kind of turns into that puzzle game
we've seen where you can actually get
your trees in it's in general not too
big of an issue and it looks good in the
end but it just makes it just makes
things a little bit more time-consuming
that I'm probably would have likes but
that being said I feel like one of the
things which I like so far about park
attacks this is gonna sound really
stupid by the way um so brace yourselves
for that [ __ ] is that is something
actually that was sort of well worded by
game grumps at some point which is the
time the the fact that poker site feels
like it has a heart to it and you feel
like there's been passion put into the
game and it's it's not just the ripoff
of anything it's actually got a saw of
its own and that's what I like about it
and it actually does do some new things
from Laurel echo ii 3 and while the
roller coaster can games in general and
it's just that's kind of like about it's
really hard to pinpoint it but and i
might be very biased about this but just
the very fact that it's made by such
small developers and really put their
heart into it and also share so much of
what they're making into the game is
something that i personally can i just
love it pretty much that's all i really
should say about that it's it's actually
been a lot of fun to just follow the
game already not even having it the game
was already very fun to look at so that
was really fun
and yeah that's kind of what I wanted to
get out about that so that being said
it's a game that I think it's fun but
it's not a game which I think I can be
creative in in the same way as well like
I said IQ in three which is why it won't
replace that game and which is why I
think these games fit very well
alongside each other but none of them
really replace each others I'm probably
not gonna drop either of them just keep
both of them going because they both
sort of fit into different interests
that I have which is cool which I do
like and yeah that's pretty much about
that he's a little Alpine house actually
that I was still bit awkward that's one
of the things though the building sets
are just too limited at the moments you
can probably find me repeating more and
more things that I've already used in
different buildings as I go on in this
park and I'm almost starting to pretty
much have a lack of things that I can do
that I really truly unique to a certain
building and instead buildings just
become copycats of other buildings I've
already built which is a bit painful but
not much that I can do about that really
with the current sets in any case I see
that I'm running out of time again next
episode I'm gonna spam grass everywhere
so that's gonna be interesting and
started work on new things which I
completely forgot what it was so see you
then